For those people
who are just out of college
that it's okay to not know.
Instead of trying
to have a clear path and destination
to where you want to be
as a mid to late career,
think about what you value.
David Weekly, thank you so much
for being on my show.
It's been seven years
since we last seen each other,
but I'm so excited
to reclaim all of that inspiration
that I had back then.
Thank you for joining me.
Pleased to be here.
Thank you.
I can't even imagine how busy
your schedule is,
given everything that you do.
And first of all,
I want to start by thanking you
for coming seven years ago
to one of the hackathons
that I organized
back in Redwood City,
Hacking Generation Y.
You gave such a wonderful keynote
that day. I keep visiting
and people have been talking about it
ever since then.
So, really thank you for talking
And it was about doing.
It was about exploring
and having passion
and having curiosity
and I'm excited to having
to let that shine through here.
I'm going to do a really brief intro about you,
even though it's not going to do justice.
But just bear with me
because I have to get
the context of who you are.
Founded PBworks,
then managing founder of Mexican.vc.
And I believe you returned 11x
on the cash-on-cash,
the most profitable Mexican VC
in history, I believe.
Entrepreneur in residence,
Trinity Ventures.
Founded Gaston Labs.
Product Manager at Facebook,
after the acquisition
of another startup of yours, Oha.na.
Head of products of various things
at Google, and most recently,
the founder and CEO of Medcorder
which I want to spend
a chunk of time talking about
because I'm just so excited
about your mission.
Hacker Dojo,
which I didn't even mention.
Way too much to talk about.
David, who are you?
How do you get
to do so many things?
What is this?
So, I'm a nerd who loves people.
And I think a lot of what I build
just comes out of that.
I like to build things.
I like to learn new technical systems.
I'm a product guy,
so I like building solutions to problems
and conspiring with other people
to go and build those things.
And then finally,
I just, I like bringing people together.
I like connecting people.
I get a lot of personal satisfaction
out of doing that.
And so, if you look at the mishmash
of stuff that I've done,
it probably doesn't seem
like it is constructed
in a coherent narrative arc.
Right?
And that's because it wasn't candidly,
you know, I think a lot
of people starting
their careers tried to ask the question
like, where do I want to be
in 5, 10, 20 years.
Like, what is my career
going to look like.
And it's a tremendously
intimidating question, right?
Because you look at people
who are very, very successful,
and I think a lot of people conclude
these people must have
just upon graduating college,
sat down, thought really hard
and come up with this beautiful story arc
of where their life was going to go
and how they were going
to get there.
And, oh, my gosh,
I don't have that written down
and or I do.
And it's not credible.
Right?
And what am I going to do?
I must be a failure because
that is the path to success,
having this clear
multi decade narrative arc
of what your career is going to be.
And if you actually get to know a number
of very famous and successful people,
generally it doesn't work like that.
Right?
That they're likely hard working,
they're likely intelligent,
they're likely charismatic
or have figured out how to be.
That's actually something
you can learn to be.
And then a number
of lucky opportunities
came about
and they were able
to take advantage of those
because they were clever
and hardworking and well-connected
and liked people
and could motivate people
to go and work on missions.
Right?
And so, life often
is much more random
that we want to give it
an account for.
So, I would say for those people
who are just out of college
that it's okay to not know.
Instead of trying
to have a clear path and destination
to where you want to be
as a mid to late career,
think about what you value.
If you enjoy learning, great.
You should make sure
that any job that you take,
you're going to be learning something.
If you enjoy having broader impact
and looking at numbers
and metrics, great.
You don't need to be embarrassed
about that.
Go run with that.
If you enjoy building something
brand new, then great.
You don't need
to be embarrassed about that.
One other thing
that often comes up
in people's career trajectories is
that they find themselves embarrassed
about things that are
off that narrative arc.
Maybe you really like
being a scuba diver,
or you like horses,
or you like spending time
learning how to go
and do ballroom dancing. Right?
And these things don't feel like
they're working toward
a successful career end point.
They are outside
of this narrative arc,
what do I do.
And what's funny is
often times these things
that make you weird,
your unique
particular collection of interests
and experiences that nobody else has
ends up making you valuable.
Right?
So, what we want increasingly
is people who are non fungible,
who can't just be swapped out
like cogs in the wheel.
But whose weird experiences
give them unique insights
and ways of tackling
the problems in front of them
that only they could have had
because only they
are coming at the problem
with those set of,
of weird backgrounds and experiences.
So, I think going back
to my own trajectory and arc,
a lot of it was like that.
It was trying to optimize for learning,
trying to optimize for impact,
trying to not be in a rut
or get bored
or not developing myself further,
always hungry to see
what problems can I solve
that need to be solved
out there in the world,
and how can I do that
in an enjoyable way.
Right?
Well, David,
how do you optimize for learning
in a world that is such
it's one convoluted race towards the top,
towards the greatest funding,
towards the greatest start,
of the greatest success?
I'm walking the streets of Palo Alto.
I'm studying with incredible people.
I've served in the Israeli military
with some incredible people.
And it doesn't feel
that always optimized
for learning is something
that one can afford.
Right?
Because we have to move so quickly.
How do you optimize for learning?
How can you possibly succeed
if you're not continuously learning.
Right?
It's that, the endpoint is not defined.
The pie is not fixed.
This is not a race where where
the rules are prescribed.
And it's clear how to succeed.
It's obvious how to build
a billion dollar company,
and you just need to sit down
and do the work. Right?
Real life isn't like that.
The new billion dollar opportunities
by definition,
haven't been sussed out,
haven't been fleshed out.
They're going to require
thinking about things
in a new way
and doing things in a new way.
You want to be cognizant
of approaches and methodologies
that are generally shown
to be successful or not successful.
So, you want to learn from
your own failures
as well as the failures
of those around you
in terms of what structurally works and not.
And I'm not saying ignore everything.
But I am saying that
that process of continually learning
is a critical one
for modern employment.
So, you take a look at
technical product management, right?
So, anyone is a PM.
Google and pretty much
anyone is a PM at Facebook.
And they need to not only have
their fingers on the pulse
of what are real unsolved problems
that are out there
in the real world.
But then, on the other hand,
they're trying to match those
to what is the state
of the art and technology.
What can you grab off the shelf
and what can I
not yet grab off the shelf,
but I have enough technical depth
to know is possible and attainable.
It is not just magic
sprinkle fairy dust. Right?
And you've got enough credibility
to go and map that out to say,
I'm going to take these four pieces,
three of which have been known
and well-defined for decades,
two of which only became possible
in the last couple of months.
And then there's this
one extra part over here
that doesn't yet exist.
But I'm confident that
with this team of engineers,
I can be able to invent on it.
And here's the reason why
I think it's tractable
and derisible from tech.
So, I'm going to put
these things together.
And I'm going to solve
the problem over here
that is otherwise unsolved.
And I'm going to be
the first person to go
and have this new way
of looking at the problem,
this new solution for this problem.
And if you are not keeping up
on not only what
was commercially viable
because it was out there,
but also as academia advances
in understanding what soon
will be possible
and what commercial impacts
that is going to have,
if you're not looking
into the crystal ball there,
you're going to miss out
on opportunities,
things that were impossible
five years ago.
You'll miss as possible solutions
because they're possible
when weren't then.
And so, you won't think to build
the product in that way,
leveraging those technologies.
So, you'll miss out.
So, there's a lot of different ways
in which in almost
any part of the stack,
whether you're a designer
or a marketer
or an engineer
or a product manager
or a CEO,
almost any role
in the company you can think of.
Even if you're doing QA testing,
the state of the art
is continuing to evolve pretty quickly.
And what that does
is it gives super powers
to the people who are able
to keep up with it.
You can see in this era,
small teams
have ridiculously sized impact
a far more than
they've been able to
pretty much any other point
in human history.
A team of a dozen
or so people can build
a product that a billion people use.
Right?
That's never believable.
It's unbelievable.
So, you think about
what do those
couple dozen people need to know?
They all need to know
how to operate at scale.
They need to be able
to harness the tools,
the methodologies,
the frameworks that are out there
to operate at scale
and to be effective
and then to keep up with that.
Now, I want to nuance that a little bit
with there's so much that's new,
always coming out
that trying to be completely on top
of absolutely every new development
in every field
is just not possible
for any human being.
Particularly, if you're also, say,
trying to build a company
at the same time.
Right?
So, you'll have to acknowledge that
even when you're trying
to optimize for learning
and keep up on things,
you're going to miss a lot.
A. That's okay.
No need to beat yourself up.
There really are only 24 hours
in the day for absolutely everybody.
And B, you can also figure out how
to leverage your networks
to help you proxy for other areas.
So, if you're focused
in some area over here,
then as long as
you know who to talk to
about some of these other areas
so they can sort of keep their ear
to the ground for you,
then you can have sort
of disproportionate impact there.
Because, I don't need to keep up
on the state of the art
and say biotech,
that's way outside of stuff
I know a lot about.
And it's okay for me
to not know a lot about that.
But it kind of interesting conversations
with friends of mine
who are deep in that.
And so, I can go and ping them
when I have questions there.
So, you don't have to do it
all yourself either.
I think that's just fascinating.
David, if I look at your trajectory
in the different things
that you've done,
the incredible things you've done,
it's a really remarkable balance
between continuing your own journey
as an entrepreneur,
as an investor,
as a thinker,
but also giving back to the community.
So many of your projects are involving
the community helping others get started,
and helping others pursue their passions.
What is that about?
Where does all this motivation
and passion for the community building
coming along with your trajectory
of being a great engineer,
great entrepreneur?
I think the short answer is
because it's fun.
It's fun to throw parties,
it's fun to introduce
people to each other
that end up hitting it off
and investing in each other,
working together to found a company.
It's fun to meet with founders
who are filled with passion
for going and bringing new products
into the world
and conspiring with them
around ways to help
their dreams come true.
It's an enjoyable thing to do.
So, even just from a
purely selfish perspective,
I help the community
because I enjoy doing that.
I think some of it also
is a critical cultural component
of Silicon Valley.
I think there's, Silicon Valley
is not a perfect place,
there's a lot of things
to hate about it.
And there's certainly been lots
of discourse around people
leaving San Francisco in particular,
which is one part of the Bay Area.
I'm going to think
that is valid and pointed.
But I think there are some aspects
of Silicon Valley culture
that are really positive
and are also "stealable".
You can incorporate these aspects
into other cultures
and other geographies as well.
And I think one of the ones that I love
is an overall pay it forward mentality.
You know, I think
most other business ecosystems
operate on a very mercenary
kind of a basis.
So, you only take a meeting
with somebody if it's clear
what they're going to be
able to do for you
and what you're
going to be able to do for them.
Right?
So, there's sort of a tit for tat.
It's a match and peers.
And it means that
it can be very difficult
to meet with people
who are powerful,
people who are wealthy.
Right?
And it's frankly,
it's a little bit more
of a fixed pie mentality.
Right?
So, they reach out the rich,
the folks who are really trying
to help folks who are early,
but it's always
in exchange for something.
And that sort of market making
where you're trying
to match up very evenly
to people who can get
the equal amount of value
for each other,
just doing the math says
there's going to be fewer
of those pairings.
Right?
But if you come at an ecosystem
with a pay it forward mentality,
there's an enormous explosion
in the number of positive connections
that can happen.
And what capitalism will tell you
is that any time there's
there's an exchange,
value is created.
Right?
And so by encouraging there
to be more of those exchanges,
by not looking
at the mercenary equal value exchange,
tit for tat,
you end up growing the value
of the ecosystem much more dramatically.
And we actually, you mentioned
you're in Tel Aviv right now.
We actually saw this happen
in the Israeli startup ecosystem,
starting with the ICQ acquisition.
Because after ICQ,
the founders turned around
and not only invested their capital,
but also their knowhow
in helping build up
the Israeli startup ecosystem.
And that really,
I would say,
just as an outside observer,
is where I really saw
things start to explode.
And so, the fact that
Israel could apply
the Silicon Valley style mentality
of reinvest your time
and your money in ecosystem,
we really saw things blow up.
So, I'm sure in Silicon Valley,
you take a look
at the most experienced
venture capital firms
that are providing
the most disproportionate return,
what's true of the VCs there,
generally,
they're disproportionately
former operators themselves.
Right?
Because they love
helping entrepreneurs.
They can give actionable
advice and guidance
on what to do at difficult parts
in the startups journey.
And they've been there before,
which gives them credibility
with founders
for highly competitive deals.
Right?
You look at the
investment ecosystem
in most other parts of the planet,
the people making
the decisions about whether or not
to back an early stage company
have never done it themselves.
And they actually down on it.
Right?
You know, when they themselves,
in a number of different ecosystems,
inherited that money
from their father's corruption.
Right?
It's so,
they're very big on themselves
and they're very down
on the lowly entrepreneurs
who have to come crawling
on their knees like,
please give me your money
esteemed investor.
Right?
And really none of that kind
of mentality or structure,
it's not present to nearly
the same extent, I would say,
here in Silicon Valley,
where it's sort of expected that
you're going to try your best
to go and build something.
If it's successful,
you're going to pay it back.
You know, whether that's
because you're going to be a VC
and help other companies succeed
or you're going to advise
and mentor others,
or maybe you're just
going to tool in your garage
and build awesome opensource
that everyone can use.
But whatever it is
that you're going to go
and pay back into the ecosystem.
A lot of the billionaires that are here
became billionaires disproportionally
because other people went
and helped them with,
again, no expectation around return.
Right?
These were people who helped
just because it was fun
to help people who
were starting things,
were finding things
and great things come out of that.
Like Pinterest was actually started
at Hacker Dojo, right?
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
What?
Lambda School as well,
started in Hacker Dojo.
Okay. So, give me two words
about Hacker Dojo
just for anybody who doesn't know.
Yeah.
So, unfortunately,
the facility is closed right now
during coronavirus.
But what it is,
it's a non-profit community center
for people go
and improve their technical skills.
So, this is helping people
who are just getting into tech
for the first time,
as well as helping people
who already maybe
have mastered some areas
of technology to come
and level up even more.
Right?
So, you can sort of think of it like
halfway between the incubator
and like an anarchist community college.
I love it.
Yeah.
So, it's just it's run
on a membership basis.
But when we're open,
we have ten times more people
than members come through
the front doors to go
and take classes
in machine learning,
Android programming,
and whatever else it is.
We've got all kinds of meet ups.
We've got a small
machine shop there,
so, you can go in
and build some physical things,
Sauter components, et cetera.
I love it.
And needless to say,
you're the chairman of Hacker Dojo.
But David, Medcorder.
I see a lot of
early stage startups right now.
Very lucky to be part
of the great VC group in Silicon Valley.
I'm not that often
has invoked emotionally when I read
even three short snippets
about what a company does.
And I know that it also has
a personal story with you.
What is Medcorder?
So, Medcorder is a free application
for Apple and for Android
that helps patients record,
transcribe and discuss medical encounters
with family members.
So, this was built after
my dad got prostate cancer
and he was on the opposite coast
from me, a couple thousand miles away.
And we wanted to work together,
figure out what was going on,
what our options were, etc.
So, he would get permission
from his oncologist
to record the audio
of the console to email that
as an attachment to me,
I'd listen through the whole thing.
I'd write up a summary,
I'd link out any medical terms or drugs
I wasn't familiar with
and I'd email the family.
The workflow works great
for getting us on the same page
about what was going on.
But it was a lot of work on my part.
It became clear that most patients
and their families didn't have
a workflow like this.
So, I started looking into recordings.
I found more than 40 years
of clinical research showing that
it's a great idea
to send a patient home
with a recording of the console
to listen to it.
Their family will listen to it.
They'll have a much greater understanding
of what the doctor said.
They'll be able to retain a lot more.
And without it, critically,
patients forget 90%
of what they're told
by the next morning.
Which means that
the actual consult at the time,
face to face with the doctor
is mostly wasted
because you're saying things
that the patient isn't able to retain.
So, I got really passionate about,
patients should have recording.
We did this nationwide survey.
We found that almost 70%
of Americans really wish they could have had
an audio recording
of their last consult with the doctor.
4% actually walk away from
that consult with the recording today.
It's surprisingly high, I have to say.
Well, that includes
the intent of our recording by the way.
Right?
So, it's one of these things
where it's not super niche.
It turns out most patients
want to better understand
their doctors and medically
will do better
if they actually understand
their doctors.
Recordings are proven way of doing this.
Sharing those recordings with families,
are proven way of doing this.
And it's not yet endemic.
It's not yet something
that is just part of the standard
of practice of medical care.
So, I started designing Medcorder
just to make it really easy
for families to go and do this.
While I was still working at Google,
I released an early
engineering prototype,
and a few weeks
after it hit the App Store,
my Aunt Terry got diagnosed
with multiple myeloma
and started using the app,
even in its very early crashy state
to coordinate her medical care
and found it transformative.
And so I was like, Oh, man.
If my aunt is finding this super helpful
for her care in its current state,
I need to take this seriously.
So, I quit my job at Google,
went full time on Medcorder,
founded a team,
raised a seed round
from Future Ventures
and built a first class
native app for both
iOS and for Android.
As well as Web interface.
And so, we've got about
20,000 patients and family members
across the United States.
We're in US only right now
that are using the app.
We've got a partnership
with UCSF Patient Support Corps.
We actually have
our first clinical trial
that we kicked off two months ago
called mENCORE to validate
the use of Medcorder
with prostate cancer patient.
So, the results of that
should be out in Q2 of next year,
where we'll be able to prove
that giving patients Medcorder is
is a really good idea
for a complex care condition.
So, I'm really passionate about
the radical proposition
that patients should understand
their doctors and Medcorder
is the vehicle for that mission.
David, so when you mentioned that
when you started off, you're still
you're just writing prototype.
So, I'm just using the prototype.
Were you writing actual prototype?
No. I'll be honest,
I contract it out with a dev shop
full stack dev shop to go and do it.
We wrote the front end in Flutter
and did the back end in Firebase.
And I was just providing
product direction.
Right?
I love it.
I mean, I love with the idea
that you obviously
have all the capabilities
you need in order to build
these things yourself,
but you're leveraging
your passion and intuition
to help get these ideas across,
even using other skills.
And we have you know,
it's a world wide economy right now.
If people all over the world
that can do it,
you're both supporting them.
You're getting this idea across
and now you've validated it.
You're going to help, you know,
potentially millions of people.
And it's almost as if
their life depends on it, literally.
Yeah.
So, I'm deeply inspired by this.
Oh, cool.
The full stack developer
who we ended up finding
through that firm
who's been full time on Medcorder
in the like for
two and a half years now,
we actually just this last month
brought on board to our team as
full time developer.
He's based in Minsk in Belarus.
Wow.
That's just wonderful.
David, 20 minutes go by
way too quickly.
I really want to thank you
for the inspiration both now
and for the time you gave
seven years ago
at Hacking Generation Y.
I just love talking to you.
I love your energy.
And I resonate so well with your
trajectory and your optimizations
for learning.
I'm curious,
passionate person myself,
and this is,
I'm very direct and honest,
this is like a role model
for me right now.
Just listening to this
and seeing your journey,
really wonderful.
Before we end,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Or that any anybody
who knows you would describe you.
I start things.
David, thank you so much.
Just phenomenal.
Thank you very, very much.
Stay safe and stealthy.
Take care.